Dr Bob Johnson
a sad day to see you go but I must
admire your principles
it's a rare sight to see a doctor stand
up to this system pioneering
psychiatrist Bob Johnson treated Charles
Bronson 30 years ago when his work was
halted Bronson wrote this letter you
believed in humanity and Trust
your way obviously worked
Bronson was jailed in 1974 for arms
robbery apart from a couple of brief
periods of Freedom he's been locked up
ever since because of repeated attacks
on prison staff and inmates
the parole board must decide what risk
he might pose to the public
should say this man has been locked up
for 50 years he has 50 years of problems
his violence and his unruly behavior is
is out of our we've decided that that's
low enough risk which I would think it
probably is but the transition as we
just said from 50 years inside to
outside life is going to be very very
dramatic
Bronson serving a life sentence for
taking a prison art teacher hostage in
1999 though he didn't hurt him
physically his victim still suffers
mentally from the trauma he has an
incredible violent streak and it's very
very risky to release people like that
and also then what happens if he is
released you know the monitoring all the
uh you know he's going to be on a life
license we know that
um but it's a very a very dangerous man
who's could be released into society you
know very shortly
recently in a voice message from his
cell Bronson who now calls himself
Charles Salvador summed up his
frustration at his continued
imprisonment
I've
ever brought to anyone what am I in
child for
last week he sent a postcard an everyday
glimpse of Freedom he urged the parole
board to show compassion for his mother
it's her lifelong dream he wrote to see
me free and happy
Martin brunt Sky News